Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. well it's june the sun's out the surf's up and who wouldn't want to be gone for the summer surfing usa unfortunately here at the rest is history myself tom holland my partner dominic sandbrook we're stuck in england we're a long way from the surf and the golden beaches of California. But all the more reason, Dominic, I think, to do an episode on the history of this remarkable corner of the world and a place that you really love, don't you?
感谢收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。嗯，现在是六月，阳光明媚，海浪翻涌，谁不想在夏天去加州冲浪呢？可惜，我们《历史余韵》的两位主播，我汤姆·霍兰德和我的搭档多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，被困在英国，离冲浪和加州的金色沙滩远着呢。但多米尼克，我觉得这恰恰是我们做一期关于这个世界非凡角落历史的理由，而且这也是你非常喜欢的地方，对吧？
I do, actually. I know my persona on the rest of this history is sort of... A grump. ...commercially cynical. The Grinch. Yeah, the Grinch. But I do love California. When I get off the plane, I've been a few times,
确实如此。我知道我在《历史余韵》里的人设有点……愤世嫉俗。……商业上的犬儒主义者。格林奇（Grinch）。没错，就是格林奇。但我确实热爱加州。我去过几次，每次下飞机，
and every time I sort of get, you know, it's that utter cliché, the sun shining and, you know, the sense of possibility and open horizon and all that sort of stuff. I mean, I absolutely am a sucker for all that. I think actually a lot of English people are, aren't they? In a way, because it's certainly within England, we project it to ourselves as the sort of absolute antithesis of the closed claustrophobic grumpy cynical world that we normally inhabit but i think for everybody i mean you know outside america but maybe even
我都会产生那种感觉，你知道，就是那种彻头彻尾的陈词滥调，阳光普照，那种充满可能性的感觉，广阔的地平线等等。我是说，我绝对无法抗拒这一切。我想其实很多英国人也是这样，不是吗？在某种程度上，因为在英国，我们把它投射为我们通常所处的封闭、幽闭、暴躁、愤世嫉俗的世界的绝对对立面。但我认为对每个人来说，我是说，你知道，在美国之外，甚至可能
within america as well in america yeah because it's the dream factory because you've got hollywood you've got tv and everything yeah to go to california even if you've never been there you kind of feel oh this is all very familiar yeah i think there's that if you have watched mad men and those of our listeners watch mad men he's in don draper the main character he's in his office in in you know manhattan and everything's going wrong and his personal life is a disaster and then every now and again he gets on the plane and he goes to california and he too he's the one man there in a suit and they're all sipping cocktails around paul's and you get a real sense of how even in the 50s that image of california is the sort of paradise as the
在美国国内也是如此，因为它是造梦工厂，因为你有好莱坞，你有电视等等。是的，去加州，即使你从未去过，你也会觉得，哦，这一切都很熟悉。是的，我想如果你看过《广告狂人》，我们的听众里有看《广告狂人》的，主角唐·德雷珀（Don Draper）在曼哈顿的办公室里，一切都乱套了，他的个人生活是一场灾难，然后他时不时地坐飞机去加州。他是那里唯一穿着西装的人，而其他人都在保罗酒吧周围喝着鸡尾酒。你真的能感受到，即使在50年代，加州的形象也是那种天堂，
world where you shed all your earthly cares and you you know the kind of kingdom of heaven there you go tom there's a gift to you um but one i'm not going to pick up because the reputation of California is kind of a place almost where you go not just to escape he's speaking as an American, like a strange history-less place, drifting along without any grasp on its own past, curiously agnostic to its own sense of self. Well, that may be true, but you are actually very interested in the history of California, aren't you? And I'm imagining that you were going to say there's an awful lot of history. Yeah.
一个让你摆脱所有尘世烦恼的世界，你知道，那是天国。给你，汤姆，这是送给你的礼物。嗯，但我不会接这个茬，因为加州的声誉几乎是一个你不仅去逃避的地方——他以美国人的身份说话，就像一个奇怪的、没有历史的地方，随波逐流，对自己的过去毫无把握，对自己的自我意识感到好奇且不可知。好吧，这可能是真的，但你实际上对加州的历史非常感兴趣，不是吗？我想你本来想说那里有非常多的历史。是的。
And actually, the weird thing is that that sense of being rootless and untethered by history is itself a historical construct. So that's kind of 20th century California, the suburban state, and the sense of it being plastic, as people have sort of entirely invented. And that's itself a product of history, but of course California does have a fascinating history, incredibly interesting. So do you know, Tom, where the name California comes from?
事实上，奇怪的是，那种无根、不受历史束缚的感觉本身就是一个历史建构。所以那是20世纪的加州，郊区之州，以及它那种虚假的感觉，就像人们完全发明出来的一样。这本身就是历史的产物，但加州当然有着迷人的历史，非常有趣。那么，汤姆，你知道加州这个名字的由来吗？
I've come prepared with a great uh i i think it comes from the name of a fairy princess in some spanish romance or something exactly so lady califia queen exactly something like that dead right so the the book is called the deeds of esplendian and it's uh by garci or donna's monteluo published in 1510 for very early very early supposed to be the most popular spanish romance before don quixote by Garci Ordonez de Monteluo, published in 1510. So very early. Yes, very early. Supposedly the most popular Spanish romance before Don Quixote. And there's a battle at Constantinople,
我准备好了，我觉得它来自某部西班牙浪漫小说里的一位仙女公主的名字之类的。完全正确，卡拉菲亚女王（Queen Calafia），差不多就是这样。没错，那本书叫《埃斯普兰迪安的功绩》（The Deeds of Esplandián），是加尔西·奥多涅斯·德·蒙塔尔沃（Garci Rodríguez de Montalvo）在1510年出版的，非常早，非常早。据说在《堂吉诃德》之前，它是最受欢迎的西班牙浪漫小说。书中有一场君士坦丁堡的战役，
or there's something going on at Constantinople, and the Black Amazons arrive, and their leader is Queen Calafia. Yeah. And this idea of the sort of slightly, yeah, this idea of the being, it's slightly Eldorado-ish, this land of gold, this land of possibility. And when the Spaniards land in California, Bia California is now the Mexican bit in 1533, they name it after the story. So right at the beginning of California's history, there's legend and storytelling and all that stuff. I can push the history of California much further back than that.
或者君士坦丁堡发生了什么事，黑人亚马逊女战士出现了，她们的领袖就是卡拉菲亚女王。是的。这种想法，有点像埃尔多拉多（Eldorado），这片黄金之地，这片充满可能性的土地。当西班牙人在1533年登陆加州（现在的下加利福尼亚州）时，他们以这个故事命名了它。所以，在加州历史的开端，就充满了传说和故事。我可以把加州的历史追溯得更远。
Please do. Okay. So the first time I went to LA, landed there, went to a kind of brilliant James Elroy type hotel. And the first place that I wanted to visit was in La Brea, where they have tar pits and in prehistoric times mastodons dire wolves saber-toothed tigers would go to these tar pits and they would sink in and they're perfectly preserved and as a child I had a an American La Brea tar pit kit you put it together and there was kind of mastodon and everything and a smilodon which is actually the the californian fossil so all the state all the states in america have fossils which i think is brilliant i didn't know that yeah so so california's is smilodon the the saber-toothed tiger anyway i i this isn't an actual history show but the reason i mention it is that um there was one human who was found in these tar pits uh and she she seems to have lived about 7 000 bc something
请讲。好的。我第一次去洛杉矶时，降落在那儿，去了一家很棒的詹姆斯·艾尔罗伊（James Ellroy）风格的酒店。我想参观的第一个地方是拉布雷亚（La Brea），那里有沥青坑。在史前时代，乳齿象、恐狼、剑齿虎会掉进这些沥青坑里，它们被完美地保存了下来。小时候，我有一个美国拉布雷亚沥青坑模型套件，你把它拼起来，里面有乳齿象之类的，还有一只刃齿虎（Smilodon），这实际上是加州的化石。所以，美国所有的州都有化石，我觉得这太棒了，我以前不知道。是的，加州的化石是刃齿虎，也就是剑齿虎。总之，这不是一个真正的历史节目，但我提到它的原因是，在这些沥青坑里发现了一个人类，她似乎生活在公元前7000年左右，
like that so 9 000 years ago and she had a wound to her skull so she has been named as um possibly california's first known homicide victim it's such a theme of californian history isn't it sort of homicide investigations absolutely so we've talked about the surf and the sun and all the kind of upbeat stuff, but California is obviously famous for its serial killers and its dodgy cops and all that kind of stuff as well. So I'm sure we'll come on to that. Anyway, I just throw that out,
也就是9000年前，她的头骨上有伤口，所以她被命名为……可能是加州第一个已知的凶杀案受害者。这真是加州历史的一个主题，不是吗？那种凶杀案调查。绝对是。所以我们谈论了冲浪和阳光，以及所有那些令人振奋的东西，但加州显然也以连环杀手、腐败警察等等而闻名。所以我相信我们会谈到这一点。总之，我只是抛出这个观点，
that perhaps we can trace the beginnings of California all the way back to 7,000 BC. Yeah, that's great. And actually, you know what, Tom? I mean, it's so interesting, isn't it, that people say, well, California's got no history. And you often hear that of America generally. People will say, particularly in the old world,
也许我们可以把加州的起源一直追溯到公元前7000年。是的，那太棒了。而且，你知道吗，汤姆？人们说加州没有历史，这很有趣，不是吗？你在美国各地经常听到这种说法。人们会说，特别是在旧大陆，
they'll say, well, America has no history. And, of course, that itself is what Americans wanted to believe, that they were starting anew, that they were leaving history behind them. And as those tar pits remind us, it does have a history. And actually, what's been written out of the history. So for example, you don't think of California typically as a place where a lot of Native Americans lived. But of course, they did. I think some historians think as perhaps a third of the entire Native American population lived in what is now roughly
他们会说，美国没有历史。当然，这本身就是美国人想要相信的，他们想要重新开始，想要把历史抛在身后。正如那些沥青坑提醒我们的那样，它确实有历史。而且，实际上，那些被从历史中抹去的东西。例如，你通常不会认为加州是很多美洲原住民居住的地方。但当然，他们确实住在那儿。我想一些历史学家认为，可能整个美洲原住民人口的三分之一居住在现在大致是
California, which is a story that you don't often hear, because you hear all about the planes and stuff, but you don't hear about the Californian. So what's, what's the story of dispossession, which I guess is also the story of, of settlement. It's just, it's the Spanish.
加州的地方，这是一个你很少听到的故事，因为你听到的都是关于平原地区之类的，但你没听说过加州的故事。那么，被剥夺的故事是什么？我想这也是定居的故事。这只是……这是西班牙人。
It doesn't, it doesn't quite fit. No, because the Spanish, see what's really interesting is people start arriving in California in the 16th century. So Francis Drake is one of those people. Yes.
这不太合适。不，因为西班牙人，真正有趣的是人们在16世纪开始到达加州。弗朗西斯·德雷克（Francis Drake）就是其中之一。是的。
Francis Drake arrives at a point Reyes and they have a service using the one of those people. Yes, of course. Yes. Francis Drake arrives at Point Reyes, and they have a service using the Book of Common Prayer, the first ever Book of Common Prayer service in the Americas. So he arrives in the Golden Hind, and then he goes off again, and there's no real attempt to settle in California by the English. And the Spanish basically use California as a way station. So it's, you know, to think that we live in an age of globalization now, but their galleons are going from Manila in the Philippines to New Spain, Mexico, the Mexico City. And California is the place where they stop.
弗朗西斯·德雷克到达雷耶斯角（Point Reyes），他们举行了一场使用《公祷书》的仪式，这是美洲有史以来第一次《公祷书》仪式。他乘坐“金鹿号”（Golden Hind）到达，然后又离开了，英国人并没有真正尝试在加州定居。西班牙人基本上把加州当作一个中转站。所以，你知道，认为我们现在生活在一个全球化时代，但他们的帆船从菲律宾马尼拉前往新西班牙（墨西哥城）。而加州就是他们停靠的地方。
So they build kind of, they have a port, I think, at San Francisco, this huge bay. And later on in the 18th century, they established the famously missions, but they're done by the Jesuits. It's not the authorities in Mexico that's doing that. So it's kind of a privatized bit almost of New Spain, run by the Jesuits. And one of them who was leading the mission, his statue got toppled, I think, last year.
所以他们建立了一个港口，我想是在旧金山，这个巨大的海湾。后来在18世纪，他们建立了著名的传教站，但那是耶稣会士做的。这不是墨西哥当局做的。所以这几乎是新西班牙的一种私有化部分，由耶稣会士管理。其中一位领导传教站的人，他的雕像我想去年被推倒了。
It got cancelled. Yeah, it got cancelled. So I guess that that's a kind of focusing the tension between the two narratives of European settlement as a process of bringing civilisation to the wilderness and the Native American perspective that this is a process of depredation and theft. Although I think actually, much as you might beat up
他被“取消”了。是的，他被取消了。所以我猜这聚焦了欧洲定居的两种叙事之间的张力：一种是将文明带到荒野的过程，另一种是美洲原住民的视角，即这是一个掠夺和盗窃的过程。虽然我认为，尽管你现在可能会抨击
on the missionaries now. Obviously, I wouldn't. Well, no, you wouldn't. At that point, I think there has been an argument that there's a devastation through disease and all that stuff. But settlers haven't arrived in big numbers at that stage. So in the 16th, 17th, even a lot of the 18th century, there really aren't many people at all. California is a long way from Mexico and from Peru. So they're the places where most of the Spanish kind of conquistadors go.
传教士。显然我不会。嗯，不，你不会。在那个时候，我认为有一种观点认为，疾病等造成了破坏。但那个阶段定居者还没有大量到达。所以16、17世纪，甚至18世纪的大部分时间里，那里真的没多少人。加州离墨西哥和秘鲁很远。所以那些地方是大多数西班牙征服者去的地方。
It's obviously a colossally long way from the east coast of what's now the United States. So if you're arriving from England, you don't keep going and go all the way to California. And actually, for a long time, there were very, very few settler people. So up to the point where the Mexicans get independence from Spain, that what there is, there aren't towns. But it's really odd because it's such an amazing place.
它显然离现在美国东海岸有极其遥远的距离。所以如果你从英国来，你不会一直走，走到加州。而且实际上，很长一段时间里，定居者非常非常少。直到墨西哥从西班牙获得独立，那里才有城镇。但这真的很奇怪，因为它是一个如此神奇的地方。
Yeah, but so much of the Americas is so amazing. Why do you need to go to the furthest bit away? I was thinking about that. Why don't people settle it earlier? And the answer is surely obvious that, you know, at the point you arrive to, to escape the new world, you know, some people settle there. And then some people go on further.
是的，但美洲的很多地方都很神奇。为什么你需要去最远的地方？我一直在想这个问题。为什么人们不早点定居？答案肯定很明显，你知道，当你到达新世界想要逃离时，有些人就在那里定居了。然后有些人继续走得更远。
So they start going to like what's now the Midwest in the United States, or they go to other bits of Mexico. But California is still hundreds of miles beyond that. Why would you keep going? But it's named after a beautiful medieval princess i mean what's not to like sort of and and there's i there's lots of there's lots of native americans that of course there's lots of resources but there's lots of resources everywhere why do you need to go on another thousand miles yeah i suppose so when so when
所以他们开始去现在的美国中西部，或者去墨西哥的其他地方。但加州还在那几百英里之外。你为什么要继续走？但它以一位美丽的中古公主命名，我的意思是，有什么不喜欢的呢？而且那里有很多美洲原住民，当然有很多资源，但到处都有资源，为什么你需要再走一千英里？是的，我想是这样。那么，
do when do english speakers start moving in i think not until the, I don't know, the gold rush. In a big way, not until the gold rush, 1848. I mean, there have been English speakers arriving. So Mexico gets independence
英语使用者什么时候开始搬进去的？我想直到……我不知道，淘金热。大规模地，直到淘金热，1848年。我的意思是，之前也有英语使用者到达。所以墨西哥获得独立
in 1821. So the Spanish Empire basically breaks up at the end of the Napoleonic Wars. Mexico gets independence and you have this period where you've got a Mexican California,
是在1821年。所以西班牙帝国基本上在拿破仑战争结束时瓦解了。墨西哥获得独立，你有了这样一个时期，你拥有了一个墨西哥的加州，
but again, there's not many people there. And the American settlers arrive, so English speakers, and you get Russians arriving. So they built a place called Fort Ross. So that's the lowest bit of the sort of Russian expansion into the Americas that you've got in Alaska, so the southernmost point.
但同样，那里没多少人。美国定居者到达了，所以英语使用者，还有俄罗斯人到达了。所以他们建立了一个叫罗斯堡（Fort Ross）的地方。那是俄罗斯向美洲扩张的最低点，你在阿拉斯加也有，所以是最南端。
But they don't do it in a big way. And then the Americans sort of take it roughly at the same time they take Texas so the Mexican-American War at the end of the 1840s and what's interesting about that, Tom is that you've got all the action in Texas and stuff that people are familiar with
但他们并没有大规模地这样做。然后美国人大约在他们夺取德克萨斯的同时夺取了它，也就是1840年代末的美墨战争。关于这一点，汤姆，有趣的是，德克萨斯发生的所有行动，人们都很熟悉，
the Alamo and these sort of scenes you've got the Mexicans and you've got Native Americans and you've got American settlers. And there's this period of intense violence. But in California, it's much more small scale. I was only reading today a description of the moment when they're raising their famous kind of grizzly bear flag and claiming independence from the Mexicans. And it's talking about the great standoff. And basically, everybody in the state arrives.
阿拉莫（Alamo）和这些场景，你有墨西哥人，有美洲原住民，还有美国定居者。这是一个充满暴力的时期。但在加州，规模要小得多。我今天才读到关于他们升起著名的灰熊旗并宣布脱离墨西哥独立的时刻的描述。它谈到了伟大的对峙。基本上，州里的每个人都到了。
They ride over the horizon. It's like 20 people or something. I mean, tiny, tiny numbers. I remember when I went to LA being very struck by the fact that apparently LA joined the union before the state of California was created. So kind of a few months before or something. Well, it's all a very shambolic process because it's being done by kind of, you know, these guys who are kind of free Because it's being done by kind of, you know,
他们骑马越过地平线。大概只有20个人左右。我的意思是，人数非常非常少。我记得我去洛杉矶时，印象非常深刻，因为洛杉矶似乎在加州建州之前就加入了联邦。所以大概提前了几个月之类的。好吧，这整个过程非常混乱，因为它是被……你知道，这些家伙，他们是……因为它是被……你知道，
these guys who are kind of freebooters. They're kind of operating independently. There's not, the main person is an officer, sort of Napoleon, he sees himself as a new Napoleon, he's called John Charles Fremont. Kit Carson is his chief scout, who was once a very famous figure in sort of Cowboys and Indians films. But they're, you know, they're quite small. It it's all quite small scale there's not that many people there so when la gets
这些家伙，他们是自由掠夺者。他们是独立行动的。没有……主要人物是一名军官，某种拿破仑，他把自己看作一个新的拿破仑，他叫约翰·查尔斯·弗里蒙特（John Charles Fremont）。基特·卡森（Kit Carson）是他的首席侦察兵，他曾经是牛仔和印第安人电影中非常著名的人物。但他们，你知道，他们规模很小。这一切规模都很小，那里没多少人。所以当洛杉矶
incorporated as a municipality its population is i think 1600 yeah tiny so that tiny that counts as a metropolis in those i mean what's that like a not even a small town is it it's basically a village kind of village yeah so then i assume what swells it is the gold rush yeah and the gold rush is a gold rush is a great story but it's a terrible story as well so a man called sutter who basically does everything because there's so few people in california he seems to do everything in california in the 1840s he's building a sawmill in what's now sacramento on the sacramento river and one of his workers, a man called James Wilson Marshall, he's sort of faffing around in the stream,
被合并为一个城市时，它的人口我想是1600人。是的，太小了。那在当时算是一个大都市，我的意思是，那甚至算不上一个小镇，对吧？它基本上是一个村庄，某种村庄。是的，所以我假设让它膨胀的是淘金热。是的，淘金热是一个伟大的故事，但它也是一个可怕的故事。所以一个叫萨特（Sutter）的人，他基本上做了所有事情，因为加州人太少了，他在1840年代似乎在加州做了所有事情。他在现在的萨克拉门托（Sacramento）的萨克拉门托河上建造了一个锯木厂，他的一名工人，一个叫詹姆斯·威尔逊·马歇尔（James Wilson Marshall）的人，他在溪流里瞎折腾，
and he finds these nuggets, shiny nuggets, and they fiddle with them for a bit, and he bangs them between rocks, and then he sees exactly that. Supposedly, he shouted, Eureka! But I don't think that's... Surely he shouted, Yeehaw! Yeah, that's ultimately very plausible. But the stats are astounding. So in 1848, do you know how many people were in California in the whole state?
他发现了这些金块，闪亮的金块，他们摆弄了一会儿，他用石头敲打它们，然后他看到了。据说，他大喊：“尤里卡！”（Eureka!）但我认为那不是……他肯定大喊的是：“耶哈！”（Yeehaw!）是的，这最终非常可信。但统计数据令人震惊。所以1848年，你知道加州整个州有多少人吗？
No, not many. Fewer than 10,000. So yeah, I mean, tiny, smaller than the population of a market town in the whole state. And in three years, more than a quarter of a million people turn up. Under their own steam, right? Yeah. So it's all wagons and... Exactly that. There aren't trains at this point. in three years, more than a quarter of a million people turn up. Under their own steam, right? Yeah. So it's all wagons and... Exactly that.
不，没多少。不到10,000人。所以是的，我的意思是，太小了，比整个州的一个集镇的人口还少。而在三年内，超过25万人涌入。靠他们自己，对吧？是的。所以全是马车和……完全正确。此时还没有火车。而在三年内，超过25万人涌入。靠他们自己，对吧？是的。所以全是马车和……完全正确。
There aren't trains at this point. It's wagons. It's arriving. I assume some are arriving by ship. San Francisco is sort of transformed into this huge port because it's exporting all the gold. They're young men. They're the 49ers.
此时还没有火车。全是马车。它是到达。我假设有些人是乘船到达的。旧金山被改造成了一个巨大的港口，因为它出口所有的黄金。他们是年轻人。他们是“49人”（49ers）。
Hence the San Francisco 49ers team. Do you know the most feared criminalsisco 49ers um team well do you know the the most feared criminals in the gold rush to california uh no but you clearly do i do uh they were apparently australian oh that doesn't surprise me at all the sydney ducks they were called and also a load of french people oh that's always a bad sign. Very, you know, unusual. Apparently 28,000 French speakers ended up in the gold rush. And I've been reading James Bell. I came across this quite coincidentally, not thinking I would be reading about California.
因此有了旧金山49人队。你知道淘金热时期加州最令人恐惧的罪犯吗？嗯，不知道，但你显然知道。我知道，他们显然是澳大利亚人。哦，那一点也不让我惊讶。他们被称为“悉尼鸭子”（Sydney Ducks），还有一大堆法国人。哦，那总是一个坏兆头。非常，你知道，不寻常。显然有28,000名讲法语的人最终参加了淘金热。我一直在读詹姆斯·贝尔（James Bell）的书，我偶然发现了这个，没想过我会读到关于加州的内容。
I'm reading James Bell, which is Replenishing the Earth, the Settler Revolution and the Rise of the Anglo World. And he is talking about the kind of the racial hierarchies in the gold rush. It's a very racist yeah it's an inclusively racist society he calls it but if you're in so you know you can be english irish scandinavian german you're treated as honorary americans everyone else isn't so that would obviously include native americans black americans mexicans but also apparently the french so the french were that's interesting
我正在读詹姆斯·贝尔的《补充地球：定居者革命与盎格鲁世界的崛起》（Replenishing the Earth, the Settler Revolution and the Rise of the Anglo World）。他谈到了淘金热中的种族等级制度。这是一个非常种族主义的……是的，他称之为“包容性的种族主义社会”。但如果你是……你知道，你可以是英国人、爱尔兰人、斯堪的纳维亚人、德国人，你会被视为荣誉美国人，其他人则不然。所以这显然包括美洲原住民、黑人美国人、墨西哥人，但也显然包括法国人。所以法国人……这很有趣。
we're treated very very badly um but some of those people must be coming from quebec i suppose yeah so half of them i think were coming from quebec and half from uh from france proper but yeah there's an there's an astronomical murder rate during the gold you know you basically the way you know you you find a load of gold and then somebody kills you for it is how it works. And especially if you're Hispanic or you're Chinese or you're... Or French. Yeah, or French as you have discovered. And the fact that I think particularly,
我们被对待得非常非常糟糕。嗯，但其中一些人一定是从魁北克来的，我想。是的，我想其中一半来自魁北克，一半来自法国本土。但确实，在淘金热期间，谋杀率高得惊人。你知道，基本上，你发现了一堆黄金，然后有人为了它杀了你，这就是它的运作方式。特别是如果你是西班牙裔，或者你是中国人，或者你是……或者法国人。是的，或者像你发现的那样，法国人。而且我认为特别的是，
basically a lot of the people who are pitching up have no experience in mining at all. So they don't know what they're doing. They just fancy some gold. And the people that they get to do a lot of the actual hard graft are people who have been doing mining
基本上，很多涌入的人根本没有采矿经验。所以他们不知道自己在做什么。他们只是想要一些黄金。而他们找来做很多实际苦力活的人，是那些已经在南美洲做过采矿的人。
in South America. So they'reileans or peruvians and they do all the hard work and then they get killed and people take off yeah people take all their gold and also has it begun so it has continued i guess you could well you could say yeah this is the kind of there's always this thing with america with all american history isn't't there, of their original sin? And you could argue that there is an original, you know, because this is also the point at which the Indian population really plummets. So the Indians are just exterminated.
所以他们是智利人或秘鲁人，他们做了所有的苦力活，然后他们被杀了，人们抢走了……是的，人们抢走了他们所有的黄金。而且它已经开始了，所以它已经持续了，我想你可以……好吧，你可以说，是的，这就是美国历史中一直存在的东西，不是吗？关于他们的原罪？你可以争辩说，有一个原始的……你知道，因为这也是印第安人口真正暴跌的时刻。所以印第安人只是被灭绝了。
They're used as child labour. Consciously, consciously exterminated. Pretty consciously. Is this kind of conscious? They're used as slaves. They're just used as disposable cannon fodder to work in the mines. So after the Civil War? What are we talking? We're talking between 1840s and the 1880s or so.
他们被用作童工。有意识地，有意识地灭绝。相当有意识。这是某种有意识的吗？他们被用作奴隶。他们只是被当作一次性的炮灰在矿井里工作。所以是在内战之后？我们在谈论什么？我们在谈论1840年代到1880年代左右。
Right. So effectively, they're being used as slaves even after slavery has been abolished. Well, I mean, you can argue. I mean, this is a huge question. You might well say the same about African-Americans, mightn't you? I mean, they are used abominably, I think it's fair to say. I mean, I don't say this as a terribly woke person myself, but the Indian population, I think, in 25 years fell from,
对。所以实际上，即使在奴隶制被废除后，他们仍被用作奴隶。嗯，我的意思是，你可以争辩。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题。你很可能会对非裔美国人说同样的话，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为公平地说，他们被极其恶劣地对待。我的意思是，我并不是说我自己是一个非常“觉醒”（woke）的人，但印第安人口，我认为在25年内从，
see, I'm very ready with the stats today, Tom. The Indian population fell from 150,000 to fewer than 30,000. So an astronomical decline. So, you know, when you go to California, now, you don't think of it as a place. The Indian, sort of Indian presence in California survives in a sort of new agey way, I suppose. But in every other respect,
看，我今天准备了非常多的统计数据，汤姆。印第安人口从15万人下降到不到3万人。所以是一个天文数字般的下降。所以，你知道，当你现在去加州时，你不会认为它是一个地方。印第安人，某种印第安人在加州的存在以一种新时代（New Age）的方式幸存下来，我想。但在其他任何方面，
it's almost been completely eradicated, hasn't it? Much as it has in, say, Argentina or somewhere. But you do, you have a continuing hispanic presence yeah yeah which is true to its history and so that's there and then you also get increasing numbers of people coming from europe of whom i guess the the most celebrated of those who help set up hollywood have i got that right yeah you've also but you have missed out the asians so the as Asian element is really important. Chinese and Japanese, actually.
它几乎被完全根除了，不是吗？就像在阿根廷或其他地方一样。但你确实，你有一个持续的西班牙裔存在，是的，是的，这符合它的历史，所以它在那里。然后你还得到越来越多来自欧洲的人，我想其中最著名的是那些帮助建立好莱坞的人，我没说错吧？是的，你还……但你漏掉了亚洲人。所以亚洲元素真的很重要。中国人，还有日本人，实际上。
So they come in the late 19th century, early 20th century, indentured labor and so on, Chinese. And they're helping to build railroads as well. Yeah. What is it, the Central Pacific or something like that? Yes, all that kind of stuff. It's huge railroads. I mean, we think of, I mean, gosh,
所以他们在19世纪末、20世纪初进来，契约劳工等等，中国人。他们也在帮助修建铁路。是的。是什么，中央太平洋铁路（Central Pacific）之类的？是的，所有那些东西。巨大的铁路。我的意思是，我们认为，我的天，
this is the great thing we do in California. When you're doing British history, you think of the age of the railways and this amazing story. And then you turn it to America and the sort of conquest of the West. And the canvas is just a thousand times larger. And they're building these massive railroads, you know, thousands and thousands of labourers. And kind of racing each other, aren't they? So people the east people going from the west exactly and people all the chinese labor is just being flogged to death again pretty
这是我们在加州做的伟大的事情。当你研究英国历史时，你会想到铁路时代和这个神奇的故事。然后你转向美国和某种对西部的征服。画布大了一千倍。他们正在建造这些巨大的铁路，你知道，成千上万的劳工。而且有点在互相竞争，不是吗？所以人们……东部的人，从西部去的人，完全正确。而且所有的中国劳工只是被鞭打致死，又一次，相当
much and that transforms the state as well tom because what you have i mean i i love this because it's one of these details of these tiny insignificant i mean i used to sort of when i was writing books about brit Britain in the 50s, I'd basically travel the land talking to people about the invention of the washing machine and how important it was. And this is a similar level. So it's the invention of the refrigerated railroad car. And that transforms California because it becomes a massive farm
多。而且这也改变了州，汤姆，因为你拥有……我的意思是，我喜欢这个，因为它是这些微小、微不足道的细节之一。我的意思是，我过去……当我写关于50年代英国的书时，我基本上会走遍全国，和人们谈论洗衣机的发明以及它有多重要。这是一个类似的水平。所以这是冷藏铁路车的发明。它改变了加州，因为它成为了东海岸的一个巨大的农场。
for the East Coast. So these colossal farms, I mean, just mind-bogglingly large to a European in the sort of interior of California, where all these sort of legions of sort of migrant workers are producing the cornucopia of fruits and vegetables. And they're sticking them in the refrigerated cars and then off they go to the East Coast. I mean, that completely transforms the Californian economy. And also the image of California, I guess, because it's from that point on, it's seen as this kind of paradise full of plenty, which I guess runs to this day. So Sunkist, Sunmade, they're both Edwardian, what we would call Edwardian brands. And before that, they've invented jeans, haven't they? Yeah, in the gold rush. But also, I tell you what, i didn't um so there's a
所以这些巨大的农场，我的意思是，对一个欧洲人来说，在加州内部，简直令人难以置信地大，那里所有的移民工人大军都在生产各种各样的水果和蔬菜。他们把它们塞进冷藏车，然后运往东海岸。我的意思是，这完全改变了加州的经济。而且也改变了加州的形象，我想，因为从那时起，它被视为这种充满富足的天堂，我想这延续至今。所以新奇士（Sunkist）、Sunmade，它们都是爱德华时代的品牌。在那之前，他们发明了牛仔裤，不是吗？是的，在淘金热中。但我告诉你，我没有……所以有一个
brilliant historian of california he's one of the great historians called kevin starr and he's written this whole sequence of books about california sort of decade by decade almost um with dreams it was always in the title it's kind of in battle dreams the dream endures and so on one of the things he talks about is how at that moment, California becomes almost like a kind of grand tour destination. So you go there from the East Coast on the train, which you couldn't do before, and you go there for health reasons or for – it becomes a kind of Mediterranean of America, you know, health and blue skies.
加州的天才历史学家，他是伟大的历史学家之一，叫凯文·斯塔尔（Kevin Starr），他写了这一整套关于加州的系列书，几乎是十年十年地写……《梦想》（Dreams）总是出现在标题里，它有点像《战斗的梦想》（Endangered Dreams）、《梦想延续》（The Dream Endures）等等。他谈论的一件事是，在那个时刻，加州几乎变成了一个大旅行（Grand Tour）的目的地。所以你从东海岸坐火车去那里，这是你以前做不到的，你去那里是为了健康原因，或者为了……它变成了美国的某种地中海，你知道，健康和蓝天。
And that's the point at which people start going to Southern California and you get this Spanish revival architecture and people build hotels. And Getty building fake Roman villas. Yeah, exactly. All of that stuff. It starts to become this fantasy world. Once you've got the railroad, you can bring people in. They're going on health retreats and all that stuff.
那就是人们开始去南加州的时刻，你有了这种西班牙复兴风格的建筑，人们建造酒店。还有盖蒂（Getty）建造仿罗马别墅。是的，完全正确。所有这些东西。它开始变成这个幻想世界。一旦你有了铁路，你就可以把人们带进来。他们去参加健康疗养等等。
We should probably take a break. But before we do that, and you talk about dreams, you talk about fantasy, I think we should talk about the beginning of Hollywood, which in a way is why everybody across the world has California in their dreams
我们可能应该休息一下。但在我们这样做之前，当你谈论梦想，谈论幻想时，我认为我们应该谈谈好莱坞的开端，这在某种程度上是为什么全世界每个人都在他们的梦想中拥有加州
and their imaginings. So tell me about the beginnings of Hollywood. Why is the film industry where it is? The honest reason is so banal, you know, you'll be disappointed. It's the weather. That's, you know, living in England, I can totally accept that. So people start, I think they start going round about the 1910s or so in a big way to Hollywood.
和他们的想象中。所以告诉我关于好莱坞的开端。为什么电影工业在那里？诚实的理由是如此平庸，你知道，你会失望的。是天气。那是，你知道，住在英国，我完全可以接受这一点。所以人们开始，我想他们在大约1910年代左右大规模地去好莱坞。
And they go there, I think, well, there's two actually reasons. One is the weather and the other is to escape regulators. So if they were doing a lot of filming around sort of New York, New Jersey, but the sort of the body that was regulating the film industry and was basically, you know, checking up on them and charging them for this and that and the other, which was called The Trust, was based in New Jersey, and they just wanted to get away and they wanted to go somewhere as sunny
他们去那里，我想，嗯，实际上有两个原因。一个是天气，另一个是逃避监管者。所以如果他们在纽约、新泽西周围拍摄很多电影，但那个监管电影工业的机构，基本上，你知道，在检查他们并向他们收取这个那个费用，被称为“信托”（The Trust），总部设在新泽西，他们只是想离开，他们想去一个阳光明媚的地方，
so they could build sets outside because they've got tons of space and they wanted weather. You know, if you're filming in with that equipment, sort of Edwardian era equipment and it rains, you know, you're buggered basically. Yeah.
这样他们就可以在外面搭建布景，因为他们有大量的空间，而且他们想要天气。你知道，如果你用那种爱德华时代的设备拍摄，如果下雨，你知道，你基本上就完蛋了。是的。
So you need to guarantee good weather to do external filming and light of course. Yeah. So it's kind of perfect. They go there and then it becomes that classic thing, you know, critical mass. There's a momentum to go there. Charlie Chaplin and Mary Pickford
所以你需要保证良好的天气来进行外部拍摄，当然还有光线。是的。所以这简直太完美了。他们去那里，然后它变成了那个经典的事情，你知道，临界质量。去那里有一种动力。查理·卓别林（Charlie Chaplin）和玛丽·碧克馥（Mary Pickford）
and Douglas Fairbanks and co pitch up there. And then suddenly it just becomes the place. The place to do it. And at that moment, at that precise moment, the European, rival European film industries are destroyed by the First World War. So they're not producing films in anything like the same numbers. And suddenly Hollywood is where it's happening.
和道格拉斯·范朋克（Douglas Fairbanks）等人去了那里。然后突然间它就成了那个地方。做这件事的地方。而在那一刻，在那一精确的时刻，欧洲的竞争对手电影工业被第一次世界大战摧毁了。所以他们生产的电影数量远不及以前。突然间，好莱坞成了发生这一切的地方。
And it becomes industrialised. They buy up all the cinemas and it becomes kind of, the industry is vertically integrated. And by the end of the 1920s, the idea of challenging Hollywood is unthinkable. I'm talking about Children's Hundreds question. Is California where history goes to die? I mean, it's also the building of ersatz history because as you say you can build huge
它变得工业化了。他们买下了所有的电影院，它变得……工业是垂直整合的。到1920年代末，挑战好莱坞的想法是不可想象的。我正在谈论“儿童百问”。加州是历史去死的地方吗？我的意思是，这也是建造人造历史的地方，因为正如你所说，你可以在沙漠中建造巨大的
great sets out in the desert so they're still there aren't they all the kind of recreations of babylon and epics and things they're very famous they're yeah they're the great ones aren't they and actually this is jumping forward a little bit but that that's what Disneyland is. Disneyland is a perfect metaphor for 20th century California, because Disneyland is built, I mean, we are jumping ahead, but it's 1955. And you go in, and it's Main Street, USA. So it's an idealized vision of a small town America that even at that moment is disappearing. And then some of the lands, you know, it's Frontierland, which is the kind of American Western, this image of the conquest of the West, and Tomorrowland, which is an image of an idealised future.
伟大的布景，所以它们还在那里，不是吗？所有那些对巴比伦和史诗之类的重建，它们非常有名，它们是……它们是伟大的，不是吗？实际上，这稍微跳跃了一点，但那正是迪士尼乐园（Disneyland）。迪士尼乐园是20世纪加州的完美隐喻，因为迪士尼乐园是建造的，我的意思是，我们跳得太远了，但那是1955年。你走进去，那是美国主街（Main Street, USA）。所以它是小镇美国的一个理想化愿景，即使在那个时刻，它也在消失。然后是一些园区，你知道，它是边境世界（Frontierland），这是某种美国西部片，这种对西部征服的形象，还有明日世界（Tomorrowland），这是一个理想化未来的形象。
And that, in a sense, is why Disneyland works so well as a kind of, as a symbol of California, because that's all that California is. It's an idealised America. It's got a kind of invented past, and it's got a kind of imagined future. That is a perfect note, I think, on which to have a word from our sponsors.
而在某种意义上，这就是为什么迪士尼乐园作为加州的某种象征运作得如此之好，因为这就是加州的一切。它是一个理想化的美国。它有一种发明的过去，它有一种想象的未来。我认为这是一个完美的节点，可以听听我们赞助商的消息。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐余韵》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are California Dreaming, and we're going to kick off the second half with a question from Nicholas Rogers AM, who asks, how much is the development of California and its major cities, especially Los Angeles, linked to water, irrigation, and the resulting politics? So Dominic, that's the stuff,
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余韵》。我们正在做“加州梦”，我们将以尼古拉斯·罗杰斯（Nicholas Rogers）AM的一个问题开始下半场，他问，加州及其主要城市，特别是洛杉矶的发展，在多大程度上与水、灌溉以及由此产生的政治有关？所以多米尼克，这就是那些东西，
as is ever the case with California, both of hardcore political history and of Hollywood, isn't it? It is. It's Chinatown, isn't it? It's the story of the great film noir, Chinatown, 1974. Yes, so a lot of California is pretty arid. And basically the story, there's this colossal growth in the 20th century.
正如加州的情况一样，既是硬核政治历史，也是好莱坞，不是吗？确实是。是《唐人街》（Chinatown），不是吗？这是伟大的黑色电影《唐人街》（1974年）的故事。是的，所以加州大部分地区相当干旱。基本上这个故事，20世纪有着巨大的增长。
I mean, astronomical growth in population urbanization. And places like Los Angeles in particular, that's a city where there shouldn't really be a city because there's not enough water. So what they did, they have this huge big public project at the beginning of the 20th century to bring water through a series of dams and reservoirs and stuff to the city to
我的意思是，人口城市化的天文数字般的增长。像洛杉矶这样的地方，特别是一个本不该有城市的地方，因为没有足够的水。所以他们所做的是，他们在20世纪初有一个巨大的公共项目，通过一系列大坝和水库等将水带到城市，
irrigate the land, basically so that they can turn it into this metropolis. And I think in LA's case, it's the Owens River that they divert and basically devastate. And yeah, there's tons of corruption, obviously, associated with these big projects. But it's an age that believes in, you know, it's an age when people believe
基本上灌溉土地，这样他们就可以把它变成这个大都市。而且我认为在洛杉矶的案例中，他们引流的是欧文斯河（Owens River），基本上摧毁了它。是的，这些大项目显然伴随着大量的腐败。但这是一个相信……你知道，这是一个人们相信
they have a right to sort of tame nature. I mean, that's part of the story of California. It's both a natural paradise and it is an object lesson in what humanity does to kind of unspoiled nature. So you have these amazing national parks and the Redwoods and, you know, Yosemite and Big Sur and these fantastic landscapes. But at the same time, you have L.A. I mean, I like L.A. and, you know, a lot of people hate it. I really like L.A., but it is kind of you know it's a it's a terribly
他们有权驯服自然的时代。我的意思是，这是加州故事的一部分。它既是一个自然天堂，也是人类对未受破坏的自然所作所为的一个反面教材。所以你有这些令人惊叹的国家公园、红杉、优胜美地（Yosemite）和大苏尔（Big Sur）以及这些奇妙的景观。但与此同时，你有洛杉矶。我的意思是，我喜欢洛杉矶，你知道，很多人讨厌它。我真的很喜欢洛杉矶，但它有点……你知道，它是一个非常
polluted it's a symbol of you know man's um abuse of the natural world isn't it it's it's also uh we talked about paris as as a cry as a city famous for its criminals with agnes parry but there's a sense i mean la as well, with London, I guess, is one of the great cities for crime. Yeah, because of Phil Norris. Yeah, Raymond Chandler. And then I guess James Elroy. Yeah, yes.
污染严重的城市，它是人类滥用自然世界的象征，不是吗？它也是……我们和艾格尼丝·帕里（Agnes Parry）谈论过巴黎作为一个以罪犯闻名的城市，但有一种感觉，我的意思是，洛杉矶也是，和伦敦一样，我想，是伟大的犯罪城市之一。是的，因为黑色电影。是的，雷蒙德·钱德勒（Raymond Chandler）。然后我想詹姆斯·艾尔罗伊。是的，没错。
So in James Elroy's novels, he's always talking about the zoot suit riots. And I'm ashamed to say I've never actually, I've never actually looked up what a zoot suit is or what the zoot suit riots and yeah i'm ashamed to say i've never actually i've never actually looked up what a zoot suit is or what the zoot suit riots are um are you are you able to answer that for me i can answer it whether the listeners will um think i know anything about it is a different matter but i can give an answer uh so california goes into the um second world war quite troubled for obvious reasons.
所以在詹姆斯·艾尔罗伊的小说中，他总是谈论“祖特服暴乱”（Zoot Suit Riots）。我很惭愧地说，我从来没有……我从来没有查过什么是祖特服，或者什么是祖特服暴乱，我很惭愧地说，我从来没有……我从来没有查过什么是祖特服，或者什么是祖特服暴乱，你……你能不能为我回答这个问题？我可以回答，至于听众是否会认为我知道任何关于它的事情是另一回事，但我可以给出一个答案。所以加州进入了
It's very vulnerable to Japanese attack. And there are Japanese invasion scares, Japanese bombing scares all the time. Steven Spielberg's one big flop, 1941. 1941, yeah. And yeah, there was this very famous occasion when people thought they were being bombed by the Japanese or Japanese planes were attacking and they weren't. But, you know, there's tens of thousands of Japanese Americans in California. They all get put in camps, basically,
第二次世界大战，由于显而易见的原因，相当困扰。它非常容易受到日本的攻击。一直有日本入侵的恐慌，日本轰炸的恐慌。史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格（Steven Spielberg）唯一的一部大失败作品，《1941》。《1941》，是的。是的，有一次非常著名的事件，人们以为他们被日本人轰炸了，或者日本飞机在攻击，但其实并没有。但是，你知道，加州有成千上万的日裔美国人。他们基本上都被关进了集中营，
moved away from the coast. There's a real sense of kind of simmering tension. I think partly because California was one of the main bases for the US Navy. So there are tons of, at any given moment, there are tons of Navy servicemen, young men, but there are also lots of Mexican-Americans who are not in the Navy,
搬离了海岸。有一种真正意义上的暗流涌动。我认为部分原因是加州是美国海军的主要基地之一。所以，在任何时候都有大量的海军军人，都是年轻人，但也有很多不在海军的墨西哥裔美国人，
who are sort of wandering about in their zoot suits. And their zoot suits, for British listeners, they're sort of the American equivalent of Teddy Boys to an extent. So they're wearing these kind of extravagant... Glosses. Yeah, they're sort of Edwardian costumes, fancy hairdos. They're very dandy-ish.
他们穿着祖特装（zoot suits）四处游荡。对于英国听众来说，祖特装在某种程度上相当于美国的泰迪男孩（Teddy Boys）装束。所以他们穿着这种夸张的……华丽服饰。是的，这是一种爱德华时代的服装，配上时髦的发型。他们看起来非常花哨。
And you can just imagine the scene. These guys are sort of swaggering down the street in what we might say is a classic kind of teenage young man way. But in the sort of racialised world of 1940s California, the US Navy guys and the Marinesines and stuff say oh who are these mexicans walking in their sort of swaggering way this is how mexicans behave it's very bad they're stealing our women blah blah blah blah and so you get these riots these um and that you know that sort of the level of violence is is disputed because of course as was the way
你可以想象一下那个场景。这些家伙以我们所说的典型的青少年那种方式在街上大摇大摆地走着。但在20世纪40年代加州那种种族化的世界里，美国海军士兵和海军陆战队员们会说，哦，这些墨西哥人怎么这样大摇大摆地走，这就是墨西哥人的行为方式，这太糟糕了，他们在偷我们的女人，等等等等。于是就发生了这些骚乱，嗯，你知道，那种暴力程度是有争议的，因为当然，就像当时的情况一样，
newspapers reported it um again in quite sort of of what you see as racialized ways. But there was a real worry. I mean, the U.S. sort of high command, that their troops would run out of control. They're basically roaming the streets, beating up Mexican streets. And interestingly, they strip them of their clothes, and particularly their trousers. It's this sort of sign that, you know,
报纸报道它的方式，嗯，再次以你所看到的种族化方式。但确实存在一种真正的担忧。我是说，美国的高层指挥部担心他们的部队会失控。他们基本上是在街上游荡，殴打墨西哥人。有趣的是，他们剥光了他们的衣服，特别是裤子。这是一种，你知道，
they're obviously trying to emasculate them in some way. And it's a real, you know, there's this sort of sign, you know, they're obviously trying to emasculate them in some way. And it's a real, there's a lot of damage, there's a lot of I don't know the I don't know offhand the sort of the toll of injuries or deaths, but it is a I think nobody died actually. But I think it's a very
他们显然是在试图以某种方式阉割他们。这是一种真正的，你知道，这是一种标志，你知道，他们显然是在试图以某种方式阉割他们。这是一种真正的，有很多破坏，有很多，我不知道，我不知道伤亡人数，但我认为实际上没有人死亡。但我认为这是一个非常
serious sort of insurrection. And so racial tensions are one of the themes particularly in LA, I guess. Yeah, I've always been. You get Watts in 1965, Rodney King, 92. But it's not always black and white. I mean, when I say black and white,
严重的暴动。所以种族紧张关系是加州的一个主题，我想。是的，我一直这么认为。1965年有瓦茨骚乱，92年有罗德尼·金事件。但这并不总是非黑即白。我是说，当我说是非黑即白时，
I mean African-Americans and sort of European-Americans. So a lot of it is to do with Hispanics or Japanese or Chinese. I mean, that's one of the things that makes California such a rich and interesting subject is the diverse. It is so diverse. Yeah. And now, obviously, is the sort of absolute, I mean, I don't want to say the melting box is such a cliche,
我指的是非裔美国人和欧裔美国人。所以很多事情与西班牙裔、日本人或中国人有关。我是说，这就是让加州成为一个如此丰富和有趣的主题的原因之一，那就是多样性。它太多样化了。是的。现在，显然，这是一种绝对的，我是说，我不想说“大熔炉”这个词太陈词滥调了，
but it obviously feels, as a European visitor now, extraordinarily Hispanic in a way that some Americans have always found makes them anxious. So that's one theme. There's another one that's highlighted by Pat Roberts, which I know is right up your street. And how has California gone from the most Republican state, the home of Nixon and Reagan, to the most democratic? So now we nixon and reagan to the most democratic so now we would think of california as absolutely you know the essence of of democratic yeah maybe even further to the left yeah than the democrats but um you know as as pat says it it's it was the base of nixon it was the base of reagan it was the base of scharzenegger um yeah but they're all well
但作为一个欧洲游客，现在感觉它确实非常具有西班牙特色，以至于一些美国人一直觉得这让他们感到焦虑。所以这是一个主题。帕特·罗伯茨（Pat Roberts）强调了另一个主题，我知道这很合你的胃口。加州是如何从最共和党的州，尼克松和里根的家乡，变成最民主党的州的？所以现在我们认为加州绝对是，你知道，民主党的精髓，是的，甚至可能比民主党更偏左，是的，但是，嗯，你知道，正如帕特所说，它是尼克松的基地，它是里根的基地，它是施瓦辛格的基地，嗯，是的，但他们都是，嗯，
the the california was always very republican i think for reasons that would appeal to you tom given your own um much stated interests so it was a particular kind of christians actually that uh that went to california so nothing to do with dinosaurs they were no sadly all romans um so when cal California massively expanded, the people who went there, the majority of them, I guess, or at least a very large plurality, were white Protestants from the American Midwest. So actually Nixon is a very good example of this. So his dad, I think, came from Ohio, and they're Quakers.
加州一直非常共和党，我认为原因会吸引你，汤姆，考虑到你自己的，嗯，经常提到的兴趣。所以这实际上是一种特殊的基督徒，嗯，去了加州，所以和恐龙无关，他们不是，可悲的是全是罗马人。所以当加州大规模扩张时，去那里的人，我想大多数人，或者至少是很大一部分，是来自美国中西部的白人新教徒。所以尼克松就是一个很好的例子。所以他的父亲，我想，来自俄亥俄州，他们是贵格会教徒。
So these guys go to California, and they are sort of sympathetic to a kind of evangelical religious tradition. So I don't know if you've ever been to it. There's an amazing building called the Crystal Cathedral in Los Angeles, which is a great symbol of this. It's a great shining glass, the world's largest glass building, an evangelical church. I mean, California is full of evangelical churches.
所以这些家伙去了加州，他们对一种福音派宗教传统表示同情。所以我不知道你有没有去过那里。洛杉矶有一座令人惊叹的建筑叫水晶大教堂（Crystal Cathedral），这是这方面的一个伟大象征。它是一座巨大的闪亮玻璃建筑，是世界上最大的玻璃建筑，一座福音派教堂。我是说，加州到处都是福音派教堂。
So these guys all went. And that tradition was very Republican. So white, Protestant, middle class, that was the bedrock of the Republican Party. And Nixon himself incarnated that. So he's from a Quaker family. He believes in kind of sobriety and thrift and all these sort of what he sees
所以这些家伙都去了。而那个传统是非常共和党的。所以白人、新教徒、中产阶级，那是共和党的基石。尼克松本人就体现了这一点。所以他来自一个贵格会家庭。他相信某种节制、节俭以及所有这些他所认为的
as traditional Republican virtues. And people always voted for them up to the 60s. And then- Then the changes. Right. And then the change happens. Then California, there's a huge demographic change. So California does become much more diverse. Those people start to lose their – so they're still there now,
传统的共和党美德。人们一直投票给他们，直到60年代。然后——然后变化发生了。对。然后变化发生了。然后加州发生了巨大的人口结构变化。所以加州确实变得更加多样化了。那些人开始失去他们的——所以他们现在还在那里，
but they're, I guess, outnumbered. But the 60s, hate Ashbury, are you going to San Francisco, flowers in your hair, all that kind of stuff. What's precipitating that because in a in a way california san francisco in particular becomes the epicenter of the 60s doesn't it it does but i guess that's because so california has massively expanded from not just from the gold rush but it's massively expanded due to the war and due to the growth of huge university complexes and things and electronics people people like hewlett packard are trading at this point you know so you have this i mean it really is the military industrial complex in action so you have all these people have moved
但我想他们的人数被超过了。但是60年代，海特-阿什伯里（Haight-Ashbury），你要去旧金山，头发里插着花，所有这些东西。是什么促成了这一点，因为在某种程度上，加州，特别是旧金山，成为了60年代的中心，不是吗？确实如此，但我猜这是因为加州不仅从淘金热开始就大规模扩张，而且由于战争和巨大的大学综合体以及电子产业的发展而大规模扩张，像惠普这样的人在此时进行交易，你知道，所以你有这个，我是说，这确实是军工复合体在行动，所以你有所有这些在40年代和50年代搬到
there in the 40s and 50s and these are now their kids who are involved in all who are driving all that so they're middle class kids by and large the universities like berkeley and stanford and so on and the university of southern california in la and there's a lot of them they're very affluent they're idealistic the vietnam war has kicked off the civil rights movement is going so that drives a lot of that they're rich enough not to have to worry about jobs yeah they're rich enough to be able to grow their beards. Of course. Yeah. That's why, actually, I bet you if you go into the sort of demographic sort of background of people who are in communes and people who are here, I mean, there's a lot of them who are in Britain. We would call them trustafarians. And I think, you know, that is a product of that big sort of demographic change and economic change that drives
那里的人，现在是他们的孩子参与了所有这些，推动了所有这些，所以他们大体上是中产阶级的孩子。像伯克利和斯坦福等等，以及洛杉矶的南加州大学，有很多这样的大学，他们非常富有，他们很理想主义，越战已经开始，民权运动正在进行，所以这推动了这一切，他们足够富有，不必担心工作，是的，他们足够富有，可以留胡子。当然。是的。这就是为什么，实际上，我敢打赌，如果你去研究那些在公社里的人和那些在这里的人的人口背景，我是说，有很多在英国的人。我们会称他们为“信托基金嬉皮士”（trustafarians）。我认为，你知道，那是那种巨大的人口变化和经济变化的产物，推动了
the sort of beach boysy and then the Jefferson airplane-ish kind of side of California life in the late and that then produces its own backlash in the form of Ronald Reagan and it darkens doesn't it oh yeah in the 60, say Charles Manson. Yeah, and California itself, I think that, and probably lots of listeners to this podcast will agree, that when you think of California, you do think, as you said, Tom, of sort of 60s California. And there is a sense in which after the 60s, when you get into the 70s, the wheels slightly begin to come off.
加州生活在后期那种海滩男孩（Beach Boys）风格，然后是杰斐逊飞机（Jefferson Airplane）风格的一面，而这又以罗纳德·里根的形式产生了反弹，而且情况变得黑暗了，不是吗？哦，是的，在60年代，比如查尔斯·曼森。是的，加州本身，我想，而且这个播客的很多听众可能会同意，当你想到加州时，你确实会想到，正如你所说的，汤姆，那种60年代的加州。在某种意义上，在60年代之后，当你进入70年代时，情况开始稍微失控。
There's a greater negativity. We're very conscious of that downside now. I mean, in the 70s, I suppose the great cultural icon that comes from San Francisco is Dirty Harry, a vigilante Republican voting cop in the form of Clint Eastwood, who then himself goes on to become Republican mayor of Carmel, right? Yeah, he does. Clint Eastwood does. And Reagan. I mean, Reagan is a Hollywood former Democrat, you know,
有一种更大的消极情绪。我们现在非常清楚这种负面影响。我是说，在70年代，我想来自旧金山的伟大文化偶像就是《肮脏哈里》（Dirty Harry），一个由克林特·伊斯特伍德饰演的治安维持者、投票给共和党的警察，他后来自己也成为了卡梅尔的共和党市长，对吧？是的，他确实是。克林特·伊斯特伍德确实是。还有里根。我是说，里根是一个好莱坞的前民主党人，你知道，
who becomes governor of California by basically saying, you know, law and order, he's going to forcibly wash hippies and make them shave their beards. And that's in the 70s? This is 66. 66? Oh, okay, about earlier. So California is always ahead of the rest of the United States,
他通过基本上说，你知道，法律和秩序，他要强行给嬉皮士洗澡并让他们刮掉胡子，从而成为了加州州长。那是在70年代吗？这是66年。66年？哦，好的，早一点。所以加州总是领先于美国其他地区，
and indeed, arguably, and we've got tons of questions about this, ahead of the rest of the Western world. And I think California was ahead and still is because of its affluence. And because it's the home of entertainment, but also of technology. So technology, computers in particular. So we're talking about the 70s, Dirty Harry. There's an argument, isn't there? When you look back in Californian history, the thing that will strike you about the 70s is things like Apple. So Steve Jobs and, you know. Yes. And they still, it's so telling that Apple still,
事实上，可以说，我们有很多关于这个问题的问题，领先于西方世界的其他地区。我认为加州之所以领先，而且现在仍然领先，是因为它的富裕。因为它不仅是娱乐之乡，也是技术之乡。所以技术，特别是计算机。所以我们谈论的是70年代，《肮脏哈里》。有一个论点，不是吗？当你回顾加州历史时，70年代最让你印象深刻的事情是像苹果这样的东西。所以史蒂夫·乔布斯和，你知道。是的。而且他们仍然，这太能说明问题了，苹果仍然，
although so many of this, basically everything now comes from China or Taiwan, but they will still have, because they assemble it and send it out from California, they still have the made by Apple in California. And that California badge is so important to Apple's branding, isn't it? That's what you feel you're buying with an Apple computer or with an iPhone. You're buying the future. Absolutely. And of course, we would now, from our perspective, see that it's Bill Gates and Steve Jobs who are the key figures in, I guess, post-war, the whole of post-war Californian history, really.
尽管其中很多，基本上现在一切都来自中国或台湾，但他们仍然会，因为他们在加州组装并从那里发货，他们仍然有“加州苹果制造”（Made by Apple in California）。而那个加州标签对苹果的品牌塑造非常重要，不是吗？这就是你觉得你买苹果电脑或iPhone时所买的东西。你买的是未来。绝对是。当然，我们现在从我们的角度来看，会认为比尔·盖茨和史蒂夫·乔布斯是战后，整个战后加州历史的关键人物，真的。
Because it's the world we live in now, the wired world, is invented in California, essentially. Yeah, and I think it probably could only have been invented in California, And because, partly because of the military, because that's the place that's been chosen for so much military spending because of the Navy bases and stuff in World War II, partly because technology has been radio and TV. Firms have been working for California for decades,
因为这是我们现在生活的世界，互联的世界，本质上是在加州发明的。是的，我想它可能只能在加州被发明出来，而且，部分是因为军队，因为那是由于二战中海军基地等原因而被选择用于大量军事支出的地方，部分是因为技术，广播和电视。公司几十年来一直为加州工作，
obviously because of Hollywood. And then you have the growth of Silicon Valley in the 70s and 80s and so many universities. I mean, California massively invested in universities in the 20th century. So Stanford, Berkeley, and the big state universities and so on. Because of that, you have this kind of,
显然是因为好莱坞。然后你在70年代和80年代有了硅谷的增长和这么多大学。我是说，加州在20世纪对大学进行了大规模投资。所以斯坦福、伯克利和大型州立大学等等。因为这个，你有这种，
all this sort of energy, which produces people like Steve Jobs and so on. And then it becomes, I mean, now they have, of have of course nick clegg they've given us the apple computer and we've given them nick clegg so you know everybody wins well so i i've got a friend who um lives in silicon valley and he very kindly took me on a tour around um all the google and Apple headquarters and things like that. And basically, it's a bit like Slough. I mean, it's... I know, doesn't it?
所有这种能量，产生了像史蒂夫·乔布斯这样的人等等。然后它变成了，我是说，现在他们有，当然有尼克·克莱格（Nick Clegg），他们给了我们苹果电脑，而我们给了他们尼克·克莱格，所以你知道每个人都赢了。好吧，所以我有一个朋友，嗯，住在硅谷，他非常友好地带我参观了，嗯，所有的谷歌和苹果总部之类的东西。基本上，这有点像斯劳（Slough）。我是说，它是……我知道，不是吗？
Considering that it's cultural, it's economic, it's financial power, it looks incredibly dull. But that's the weird thing about it, isn't it? Because sometimes when we've been to California, we'd say, oh, wouldn't it be amazing to live here and stuff? But there is this kind of sense that you're just living in a massive suburb i mean i apologize to our californian listeners i think we've been very i think we've been full of praise for california so it's it's time to to be a bit rude about if you lived in la if you lived in la i mean i love la i like going to la i like the sense of and it
考虑到它是文化、经济、金融力量，它看起来令人难以置信地沉闷。但这就是关于它的奇怪之处，不是吗？因为有时当我们去过加州时，我们会说，哦，住在这里不是很棒吗之类的。但有一种感觉，你只是住在一个巨大的郊区。我是说，我向我们的加州听众道歉，我想我们一直非常，我想我们一直对加州赞不绝口，所以是时候对它有点粗鲁了。如果你住在洛杉矶，如果你住在洛杉矶，我是说，我喜欢洛杉矶，我喜欢去洛杉矶，我喜欢那种感觉，而且它
is that that sense of you know i'm now an extra in a Hollywood movie. I'm walking around places that I've seen on TV. It's the most exciting place to go. I completely agree. I mean, if you're not from California, you feel like you're kind of coming home to your own dreams when you go there. You do. And it is incredible.
是那种，你知道，我现在是好莱坞电影里的临时演员。我在电视上看到过的地方走来走去。这是最令人兴奋的地方。我完全同意。我是说，如果你不是来自加州，当你去那里时，你会觉得你好像回到了自己的梦想中。你会的。而且它令人难以置信。
But then if you sort of said, imagine living at number 100, 1,000, you know, 1128 something drive. Palo Alto. Yeah. And you've got this massive house and a pool. I actually wouldn't know what, I wouldn't know what to do with myself. Except that actually, you know, if you're in Silicon Valley, the likelihood is your house isn't going to be that massive. No.
但如果你说，想象住在100号，1000号，你知道，1128号某某大道。帕洛阿尔托。是的。你有一个巨大的房子和一个游泳池。我实际上不知道，我不知道该拿自己怎么办。除非实际上，你知道，如果你在硅谷，你的房子不太可能那么巨大。不。
So even if you're. Jeff Bezos is living in the big house and you're living in the shack at the bottom of the road. Well, we looked at Zuckerberg's house. It was actually quite, you know, I mean, it's big, but it wasn't kind of Blenheim Palace or Versailles big. Yeah. And I guess that one of the questions that hangs over California now
所以即使你是。杰夫·贝佐斯住在豪宅里，而你住在路尽头的棚屋里。好吧，我们看了扎克伯格的房子。它实际上相当，你知道，我是说，它很大，但它不像布伦海姆宫或凡尔赛宫那么大。是的。而且我猜悬在加州头上的问题之一现在是
is that essentially it's created the future twice. So it's created the future with Hollywood and then it's created the future with computing internet all that kind of stuff but um the question then is would it be able to do it again or has it become too stratified too much the victim of his own success are those at the top so wealthy yeah and that that essentially there's no way in now for those at the bottom. Would Steve Jobs now be able to make his way and start something up from scratch? Well, that's a good question because I think one of the issues with California is how it has become an object lesson in the rich and the poor. And there was a real – it's something that is very noticeable
本质上它已经两次创造了未来。所以它用好莱坞创造了未来，然后它用计算、互联网所有这些东西创造了未来，但是，嗯，问题是它是否能够再次做到这一点，或者它是否已经变得过于分层，过于成为自身成功的受害者，那些处于顶层的人如此富有，是的，而且本质上对于那些处于底层的人来说，现在没有进入的途径。史蒂夫·乔布斯现在还能白手起家创造出什么东西吗？好吧，这是一个好问题，因为我认为加州的问题之一是它如何成为了贫富差距的典型案例。而且有一个真正的——这是非常明显的
as a British visitor to California. I'm not claiming that Britain is perfect by any means, but the the shoddiness of some of the public infrastructure so for example dick of axe dick of axis question right how is it that a very rich and cultured state also has massive homelessness problems where i've been told that human excrement you love a bit of human excrement is common to find in places like california opportunity for a call back to parallels with paris street urination so you can be rude about paris again and yeah so i have seen people urinating the streets in paris i've never
作为一个英国游客去加州。我并不是说英国在任何方面都是完美的，但一些公共基础设施的破旧，所以例如迪克·阿克斯（Dick of Axis）的问题，对吧，为什么一个非常富有和有文化的州也有巨大的无家可归问题，我被告知人类排泄物，你喜欢一点人类排泄物，在像加州这样的地方很常见，这是一个回溯巴黎街头小便的机会，所以你可以再次对巴黎粗鲁，是的，所以我确实在巴黎街头看到过人们小便，我从来没有
seen them doing it in california but dick of axes is onto something that there is a huge homelessness problem um uh you know places like san francisco have become very much a city of the haves and have nots but also there's generally an infrastructure problem so california has constant problems with the schools being hideously underfunded. Now, part of this, Tom, and this will not surprise you coming from a well-known Marxist historian,
在加州看到过他们这样做，但迪克·阿克斯说到了点子上，确实存在巨大的无家可归问题，嗯，你知道，像旧金山这样的地方已经变得非常像一个贫富分化的城市，而且通常也存在基础设施问题，所以加州一直存在学校资金严重不足的问题。现在，部分原因，汤姆，作为一个著名的马克思主义历史学家，这不会让你感到惊讶，
the answer to this is very simple. Californians don't pay enough tax and they haven't paid enough tax since the 1970s. For you and your left-wing opinions. And one reason for that is that they have a very unusual kind of politics
这个问题的答案非常简单。加州人交的税不够，而且自70年代以来他们交的税一直不够。为了你和你那左翼的观点。而原因之一是他们有一种非常不寻常的政治，
that definitely will appeal to you. Yes, well, Simon Girdleston coming in again with some questions to what extent is california the product of its strange constitution direct ballot amendments introduced laws are often very liberal e.g. on free speech or conservative law and order and all exist at the same time impossible to change without another plebiscite plebiscitary politics that is california has been doing that for decades and it is a real, I think, a problem. Basically, we often ask in Britain, don't we, if politics turned into a colossal reality show and people were voting about everything, they were invited to vote. That's basically what California politics is. They have propositions. You'll have often seen people, our Britishers will have seen them
这绝对会吸引你。是的，好吧，西蒙·格德尔斯通（Simon Girdleston）再次提出了一些问题，加州在多大程度上是其奇怪宪法的产物？直接投票修正案引入的法律通常非常自由，例如关于言论自由，或者保守的法律和秩序，所有这些都同时存在，没有另一次公民投票就无法改变。公民投票政治，这就是加州几十年来一直在做的事情，我认为这确实是一个问题。基本上，我们在英国经常问，不是吗，如果政治变成了一个巨大的真人秀，人们对一切进行投票，他们被邀请去投票。这基本上就是加州政治。他们有提案。你经常会看到人们，我们的英国人会看到他们
report to the newspapers, Proposition 12, Proposition 13, Proposition 7, to change, to basically limit, often to limit the powers of government. The most famous one is Proposition 13 from the 1970s, which limited how much you could charge in property taxes. Right. And so that's why, and so that's then the root of the problem. So they don't pay enough tax. I mean, and it's very hard to argue, to persuade people that they ought to pay more tax. And I think, yeah. And there's also an eccentricity in California politics. There's always been...
向报纸报告，第12号提案，第13号提案，第7号提案，去改变，去基本上限制，通常是限制政府的权力。最著名的是70年代的第13号提案，它限制了你可以征收多少财产税。对。所以这就是为什么，所以这就是问题的根源。所以他们交的税不够。我是说，而且很难争论，很难说服人们他们应该交更多的税。而且我认为，是的。而且加州政治中也有一种怪癖。一直都有……
Governor Moonbeam. Yeah. Governor Moonbeam was Jerry Brown, obviously Schwarzenegger. Now, the weird thing about Schwarzenegger was he's actually a very moderate Republican. So he's actually quite in tune with California's political history.
“月光州长”（Governor Moonbeam）。是的，“月光州长”是杰里·布朗（Jerry Brown），显然还有施瓦辛格。但是，关于施瓦辛格奇怪的事情是，他实际上是一个非常温和的共和党人。所以他实际上与加州的政治历史相当合拍。
But of course, you know, former Austrian bodybuilder, the Terminator, you know, there's a slight sense of owning California and you have this sort of celebrity political culture. Well, I'm glad you mentioned Terminator because of course one other thing that we should mention about California, perhaps before we finish,
但当然，你知道，前奥地利健美运动员，终结者，你知道，有一种稍微拥有加州的感觉，而且你有这种名人政治文化。好吧，我很高兴你提到了终结者，因为当然，在我们结束之前，我们应该提到的关于加州的另一件事，
is the fact that it's built on the San Andreas Fault. And therefore it's the, you know, it's like building Pompeii on the slopes of Mount Vesuvius, except that Californians know that the big one may be coming. And I speak as someone whose wife was in Palo Alto in the 1990 earthquake. Really? She was living in a trailer. Gosh, that's glamorous generous which was the best best
是它建立在圣安德烈亚斯断层（San Andreas Fault）上的事实。因此，它就像是在维苏威火山的斜坡上建造庞贝城，只不过加州人知道“大地震”（the big one）可能即将来临。我以一个妻子在1990年地震时身处帕洛阿尔托的人的身份说话。真的吗？她当时住在一个拖车里。天哪，那真是奢华，慷慨，这是最好的
place to be yeah i can imagine she just stood in the middle of the trailer she and her friends and they were they were fine um and there's a sense isn't there in which um thanks to hollywood and thanks to the threat of of earthquakes and the you know the various disastrous earthquakes that have hit San Francisco and LA and all these incredibly famous cityscapes, that California, although it stands in for a kind of utopian vision of the future, is also the most dystopian place on earth. This is, California offers us a vision
地方，是的，我可以想象，她只是站在拖车中间，她和她的朋友们，他们都很好，嗯，有一种感觉，不是吗，多亏了好莱坞，多亏了地震的威胁，以及，你知道，袭击旧金山和洛杉矶的各种灾难性地震，以及所有这些令人难以置信的著名城市景观，加州，虽然它代表了一种乌托邦式的未来愿景，但也是地球上最反乌托邦的地方。这是，加州为我们提供了一个愿景
of the horrors that may be coming. So whether it's Blade Runner, probably the most influential vision of the future that's ever been made, or whether it's all the aliens and cyclones and monsters from the sea that periodically wipe California out. So we've got a question from Steven Jensen, friend of the show. Has California become a kind of bellwether state for the rest of the US culturally, economically, politically, technologically, demographically, showing how the rest of the country might look 10 to 20 years in the future? I'm sure that's true. I don't know. But I think definitely it serves as a kind of a template for how the rest of us in the world kind of imagine the future.
关于可能到来的恐怖。所以无论是《银翼杀手》（Blade Runner），可能是史上最具影响力的未来愿景，还是所有那些定期摧毁加州的来自海洋的外星人、气旋和怪物。所以我们有一个来自史蒂文·詹森（Steven Jensen）的问题，节目的朋友。加州是否在文化、经济、政治、技术、人口上成为了美国其他地区的某种风向标，展示了该国在10到20年后可能的样子？我相信这是真的。我不知道。但我认为它绝对是作为一种模板，让我们世界上的其他人想象未来。
It is. And I'm glad you mentioned later on it, because, of course, Philip K. Dick is a great Californian writer and these sort of dystopian visions of the future. And I mentioned the historian Kevin Starr earlier on, so people who are interested in California should definitely check out his books. His emphasis on dreams, but he also talks a lot about nightmares. And I don't know that there's ever been a place, I mean, you'll know better than me, whether there are people in the classical world or something, ever had a sense of a particular place that embodied
它是。我很高兴你提到了它，因为，当然，菲利普·K·迪克（Philip K. Dick）是一位伟大的加州作家，还有这些反乌托邦的未来愿景。我之前提到了历史学家凯文·斯塔尔（Kevin Starr），所以对加州感兴趣的人一定要看看他的书。他强调梦想，但也谈论了很多噩梦。我不知道是否曾经有过一个地方，我是说，你会比我更清楚，古典世界或其他地方的人是否曾经对某个地方有一种感觉，体现了
the sort of possibility and the peril of human civilization so california has now become i think actually in some ways more strongly dystopian than utopian don't you that um we have a sort of a fear of what california may represent rather than a i mean of course we still have the sort of hollywood romantic yearning. Don't you think the fear is stronger now? I suppose because we've lived through a dystopian age period, we've, you know, the pandemic is the kind of thing that, that hits California in, in Hollywood films.
人类文明的可能性和危险，所以加州现在已经成为，我认为实际上在某些方面比乌托邦更强烈地反乌托邦，不是吗？我们对加州可能代表的东西有一种恐惧，而不是一种，我是说，当然我们仍然有那种好莱坞式的浪漫渴望。你不觉得现在的恐惧更强烈吗？我想因为我们经历了一个反乌托邦的时代，我们，你知道，大流行病就是那种，在好莱坞电影中袭击加州的事情。
And that's what everyone said is, oh, it's just like a movie. And it's a movie because people in California have, have, have been giving portrayals of the future. That's exactly like that. What's that? If there's ever been a place like California before, do you think there's ever been anywhere like it?
而每个人都说的是，哦，这就像一部电影。这是一部电影，因为加州的人们一直在描绘未来。这完全是那样的。那是什么？如果以前曾经有过像加州这样的地方，你认为曾经有过像它这样的地方吗？
Oh, I think, I mean, you know, I said one of the things that, that I found bizarre about the lack the relative lack of swagger about these great Silicon Valley behemoths is that absolutely, you know, Alexandria or Rome or Babylon or Baghdad or whatever, these were great cultural centers where people who lived there felt that they were
哦，我想，我是说，你知道，我说过我发现关于这些伟大的硅谷巨头缺乏那种相对的“大摇大摆”感到奇怪的一件事是，绝对，你知道，亚历山大港或罗马或巴比伦或巴格达等等，这些都是伟大的文化中心，住在那里的人觉得他们
at the center of the world and they wanted to create monuments that would demonstrate that. In a sense, that's kind of what is lacking in the infrastructure the built-up spaces of california the the lots of the most famous buildings are ersatz buildings so whether it's the the hearst castle or the getty villa or whatever these are you know the very style of architecture is kind of pastiche across a lot of la california spanish revival kind of colonial revival stuff is pastiche but the real that you know the real monuments to californian wealth and power it is virtual i mean it's online it's it's what we're doing now we're recording recording this using iPhones, using Zoom on computers
处于世界的中心，他们想创造能够证明这一点的纪念碑。在某种意义上，这就是加州的基础设施、建筑空间所缺乏的东西，很多最著名的建筑都是仿制品，所以无论是赫斯特城堡（Hearst Castle）还是盖蒂别墅（Getty Villa）等等，这些都是，你知道，建筑风格本身就是一种拼贴，洛杉矶加州的大部分西班牙复兴风格、殖民复兴风格的东西都是拼贴，但真正的，你知道，加州财富和权力的真正纪念碑是虚拟的，我是说，它是在线的，它是我们现在正在做的事情，我们正在录音，使用iPhone，在电脑上使用Zoom
in a way that would have been unimaginable even 10 years ago, even, well, I guess even two years ago, perhaps. But we can do that because, in a sense, what we're doing is Californian. And that's the monument that it's raised, I think. Yeah, that's a great note. So much to end, I think. We're all living in a Californian world. Yes, okay.
以一种即使在10年前，甚至，好吧，我想即使在两年前都无法想象的方式。但我们可以这样做，因为在某种意义上，我们正在做的事情是加州式的。我认为这就是它竖立的纪念碑。是的，这是一个很好的注脚。我想以如此多的内容结束。我们都生活在一个加州的世界里。是的，好的。
We need to get back to much more distant periods, I think. So next week, Tom, we'll be having a podcast just like, uh. I think we're doing, aren't we doing, we're doing Hitler. No, we are doing Hitler. We're not doing Hitler. So that really is dystopian. So that's, and we've got, who are we doing?
我想我们需要回到更遥远的时期。所以下周，汤姆，我们将有一个播客，就像，呃。我想我们正在做，我们不是在做，我们正在做希特勒。不，我们是在做希特勒。我们不是在做希特勒。所以那确实是反乌托邦的。所以那是，而且我们有，我们在做谁？
We're doing Hitler with Sir Ian Kershaw. We're doing Hitler with Sir... Of course we are. That is a very exciting moment for our podcast because I would say, partly because he gave me my first academic job, I would say he has a very good claim to be Britain's greatest living historian.
我们正在和伊恩·克肖爵士（Sir Ian Kershaw）一起做希特勒。我们正在和爵士一起做希特勒……当然我们是。这对我们的播客来说是一个非常激动人心的时刻，因为我会说，部分是因为他给了我第一份学术工作，我会说他非常有资格成为英国最伟大的在世历史学家。
So I'm very much looking forward to that. And definitely our leading biographer of Hitler. Definitely. Something to look forward to. But before Suryan and Hitler, Tom, we have Magna Carta. Magna Carta, yes, of course we do. With Professor Ted Vallance from the University of Roehampton, a friend of ours, who will be telling us whether Magna Carta died in vain,
所以我非常期待这一点。而且绝对是我们领先的希特勒传记作家。绝对是。值得期待的事情。但在伊恩爵士和希特勒之前，汤姆，我们有《大宪章》（Magna Carta）。《大宪章》，是的，当然我们有。与罗汉普顿大学的泰德·瓦伦斯（Ted Vallance）教授，我们的朋友，他将告诉我们《大宪章》是否白死了，
whether Magna Carta matters. He's got a blog called Magna Carta Balls, or at least he had a blog. So it gives you a clue. There was no one better. Tune in on Thursday to hear that and tune in next week to hear Ian Kershaw on Hitler. And we'll have loads more on that.
《大宪章》是否重要。他有一个博客叫“大宪章胡扯”（Magna Carta Balls），或者至少他曾经有一个博客。所以这给了你一个线索。没有比这更好的人了。周四收听节目来听那个，下周收听伊恩·克肖谈论希特勒。我们将有更多关于那个的内容。
So we will see you soon. Thanks a lot. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们很快就会见到你。非常感谢。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。